il y a dix ans on nous obligeait les
compagnies de tabac à tapisser les
paquets de cigarettes de photos
explicites et de messages sur les effets
nocifs du tabac cela t-il convaincu les
fumeurs l'écraser les fesses du lapacca
cigarette c'est dissuasif quand même
pas regardé le pack cascade je crois
qu'ils ont raison de faire ça preuve que
la partie n'est pas gagnée
malgré tout ces deux fumeurs n'ont
toujours pas arrêté j'avais arrêté ça
complètement je recommençais et
peut-être 2 1 on touche au nom des rails
nous sommes dans quelle période se meut
peu que le tabagisme continuent d'être
une cause majeure de maladies évitables
48 mille canadiens meurent encore de
maladies liées au tabac chaque année
ottawa fait le constat qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin dans la lutte au
tabagisme une entre gouvernement propose
une mise à jour des règlements pour
l'équipage dorénavant sur chaque
cigarette un message sera imprimé
impossible d'y échapper quelques mots
comme ceux-ci du poison dans chaque
bouffée l'objectif est de réduire de
plus de la moitié le nombre de fumeurs
au canada ils représentent actuellement
13% de la population
le gouvernement espère qu'il en restera
à peine 5% en 2035 elles sont
vieillottes et l'information n'est pas
toujours à jo la coalition québécoise
pour le contrôle du tabac crois qu'il
est grand temps de mettre au goût du
jour la stratégie anti tabac on n'en les
rangs du loch et surtout quand on sait
qu'on que plusieurs jeunes vont
s'échanger des ddd cigarettes ont
emprunté une cigarette etc donc ils ont
ils font pas toujours l'achat d'un
paquet mais elle ne se fait pas
d'illusion elle s'attend à une riposte
des compagnies de tabac ils ont la
capacité et l'argent pour changer
régulièrement leurs produits santé
canada va d'ailleurs demander l'avis des
compagnies de tabac en plus de tenir des
consultations publiques qui s'étendront
sur plus de deux mois les premières
cigarettes arborant un message de santé
publique seront en vente au plus tôt à
l'automne 2023 ici valérie gamache radio
canada ottawa